what is the middle of this
you [ __ ] let me know
Angela better be glad she didn't end up
in somebody's jail that night I don't
know if she's doing this for Ratings or
what but this is abuse
plain and simple it's abuse
yes Angela runs up on Michael and
attacks him after she pops up on him
unannounced in Nigeria welcome to my
place without telling me thank you
yeah Michael is understandably fired up
but doesn't hit back instead he ends up
in tears
I tried for four months [ __ ]
wow Young Money says quote Angela's a
type who physically beats her boyfriend
then brags about being tough when he
doesn't stoop to her level the money
you're on to something there let's get
into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's malicio before
we get into Angela losing it I have a
couple quick updates on some other
couples just to keep you in the loop
first up Jenny and submit
some easy all the eyes
Jenny watch your steps is it just me or
does she see that shoe
[Music]
I was wondering for a minute if that was
staged or not it just seems like she
looked down at the shoe but maybe she
didn't maybe it was too late
[Music]
I always leave your shoes in the middle
of the floor anyway after telling submit
she was not interested in taking a
Kamasutra yoga class to spice up their
sex life Jenny changed her mind for the
sake of their relationship I don't want
to have to be doing all these different
positions poses in bed
okay leg straight leg straight Jenny and
submit practice some new moves in the
class
wow
okay Danny I I thought you lost some
weight but you
you lost more than I thought shut up and
good news is that when Ginny left she
was ready to be more adventurous in the
bedroom on the practice all of this okay
maybe it's gonna help uh we could try
the cowgirl Cowboy one yeah
[Laughter]
probably jumped on top of him you know
and ride them like a pony
a pony yeah but thank you submit said oh
I'm a pony not a full grown horse
okay a pony yeah well thank you these
two turn into teenagers during moment
this it's so cute all right next up Big
Ed calls off his engagement to Liz who
cares like really who cares I know most
of you don't but I'm telling you so you
can have the information apparently at
their engagement party Liz had an
interaction with this girl and that led
Ed to believe Liz and the girl had a
romantic past together and I see a
friend of Liz grab her by the arm I know
her she's a lesbian and this looks like
uh an emotional fight
it's the way that people have been
intimate look at each other
seriously
I don't know if that's what you're gonna
think Liz who had a bit too much to
drink by the way runs off from the party
luckily she had a camera crew that would
follow her you are out of control you're
drunk shut the [ __ ] up yeah Ed ends up
calling Liz as she walks to God knows
where and tells her she's not ready to
get married let's leave the ring and Pat
your stuff and move out you're not ready
to get married
I'm not ready to get married
is Ed I want to marry you I want to
spend the rest of my life with you but
until I know
till I know everything about you Liz I
can't I'm not gonna I we can't that
would be foolish and you're hiding
something oh I hope someone grabbed the
ring because it definitely fell see that
Ed and Liz a day wasn't too bad you
survived all right on to the 90 Day
Fiance and Mari Povich Show crossover
event I only say that because ever since
I saw Angela Omari powder
I see how she brings that same energy to
90 day where she just turns up to a
thousand in front of the camera for no
reason now I know that a part of it is
just her personality but it feels like
she's always trying to put on a show
that someone necessarily dramatic tell
him I'll break the windows next you have
to rhyme
Michael get your butt out of here your
car's getting jacked up all right Angela
and her friend Renee are in Nigeria and
at Michael's home unannounced Angela
traveled there to see if Michael's
scamming her after he refused to take
down his Instagram I gave Michael one
last chance to take down that damn
Instagram and he had the nerve
to text me
l-o-l no
[Applause]
Angela doesn't want Michael on social
media because she's concerned about him
talking to other women meanwhile
Michael's just trying to get paid as an
influencer
foreign
it's the middle of the night and I'm
tired but I'm really exhausted from
Michael's constant disrespect I'm
knocking on his door I'm calling his
name and he won't even come out the damn
house do you know how that makes me feel
as his wife I'm not just coming across
the damn streets I have flew across the
world
you are a breakup you divorce me this is
my car Jonesy says quote Angela is
insane she must be going through
menopause to act like that shaking my
head Jonesy is that rude or honest
maybe I need to ask my mom Michael
really is not who he presents himself be
I've never heard who I am
I'm a fighter I'll be a fighter today
and I but that's not allow me now I'm
not hurt oh we know you are hurt people
hurt people
[Music]
she's ruining his car tell him to come
out after Angela bangs on his door and
tears his car apart Michael finally
comes out of the house
and Angela runs up on him like she's
some gangster in the street and Michael
just stole something from her
Renee
hush
[Applause]
your friend already pulled you into this
mess
oh this man in the orange dinner woke up
to a nightmare look at his face
where is security by the way why doesn't
production have security with them they
should knowing that Angela was
confronting Michael I was crazy
this dick you are the one I trusted you
are you're a baby a man you you want a
baby a man that broke my heart
him
his family because his family love me
they would see past Michael's well your
BS is in the way how can anyone see past
that hell if they don't know Michael
lies and they don't know their brother
he might be scaring me ever since I
signed I do this man everything went
down here I'm done with it I'm done
you will not come on Visa
I cried for four months [ __ ]
say that again Michael
I'm dying
Angela let's go I trusted you y'all
should have done that a long time ago
poor man in the orange had to suffer by
the way I think that's Michael's brother
I'll be back to get my car
[Music]
I want to bring up this comment from Lex
she says quote imagine if Michael did
this to Angela everyone would be
outraged
so true just imagine
oh
Lex goes on to say quote everyone
deserves respect she is very hostile and
disrespectful I pray they both walk away
before someone is truly hurt or arrested
that last sentence definitely I've never
been in an abusive relationship Lord
forbid I ever will but in the cases that
I've witnessed unfortunately sometimes
it takes things getting so bad that the
person who's getting abused has no
choice but to walk away and I don't mean
to make this too heavy but the reality
is is that everyone doesn't get to walk
away
so embarrassing after the altercation
Angela says she's embarrassed but she
didn't say it was because of her actions
yeah
tell my husband Jimmy
I'm done I'm going home I'm going to the
airport and I'm getting the Nigeria and
I don't ever want to look back
I fight because I do believe in my
marriage I really take that serious
my intentions was to give him the
benefit of the doubts
I really had hopes that we would
click again
right now I'm hurt I still love it
she doesn't even realize that she's
working against the very things she
wants which is to receive love I know
I've said this before but I'll say it
again therapy helps a lot of us are
working through childhood trauma that's
showing up in our adult relationships
I'm not a professional but in my opinion
it seems as if somewhere along the line
Angela started to believe that this way
of acting out gets her what she wants
but now that she's an adult she needs to
realize and accept that this tactic of
raising hell as she would call it
doesn't work it's actually not getting
her what she wants if anything is moving
her farther away from it I really had
hopes that we would
click again
right now I'm hurt but I still love it
I know it's my job to talk about the
biggest must-see moments from these
episodes but a part of me doesn't feel
right just snacking on this as a piece
of entertainment
so instead of ending things on the
shenanigans I just want you to know
don't get sentimental oh I am and I
don't care if it makes you uncomfortable
you'll be okay anyway I just want you to
know that whether you think you do or
not you deserve the best you deserve to
be in a relationship with someone who
makes you feel good about who you are
and who protects you yeah we can't
always rely on our partners to fill us
up but they also shouldn't be draining
us of course there are resources to help
move this conversation along like
therapy and I also have the National
Domestic Violence Hotline here on a
lighter note cmcd says quote I want to
see Michael on the single life finding
him a good woman
that would be something he might have to
give us his dreams of Living in America
though I would love to see him date in
Nigeria that would be cool single life
the other way
I'm just tired of me to just go home all
right naughty day fan spam next week
Angela and Michael meet face to face to
talk after this blow up you can't get on
a plane and not have a conversation with
that man
how do you really know when it's time to
end a marriage oh it is time it's not
only emotionally it's painful at this
point like when is it okay for me to
give up
I can't wait to see what they have to
say
make sure you stick with ET because we
are covering it all I will see you next
time
[Music]